yesterday i talked generally about
the white house press corps apparent
inability or lack of desire to ask
serious questions of white house press
secretary jen saki
we talked yesterday about the dogs and
cats
questions from the previous day today i
want to drill into
a two-minute exchange between jen saki
and fox news reporter peter ducey
now i'm going to admit up front because
i think it's more interesting
if i'm honest with you there is a kernel
of a good topic here that peter tries to
bring up
but he's so blinded by his desperation
to be hysterical and histrionic uh and
and make the exchange as confrontational
and dramatic as possible
that what could be an interesting topic
gets lost in the noise of hyperbole
i won't say more let's just hear the
question and then we'll talk about it
cdc tells these migrant shelter
facilities
that they can be at full capacity if
they are careful about covid
many of them do but when the cdc tells
schools
that they can open in person at full
capacity many of them don't
is there a school in particular that you
have as an example that didn't
do that are most schools in this country
at full capacity with
in-person learning so the question in
general
is fair but he asks it in a completely
dishonest deceptive and needlessly
dramatic way
he says how can the same cdc be saying
child
migrant detention facilities at the
border can be open at full capacity
but schools can't open at full capacity
because it's too dangerous
the fair part of this question is that
in both schools and migrant centers
both have the potential to have a lot of
kids crowded together
and we have a pandemic why can one be
open and the other one can't
that's a perfectly fair kernel of a
question
now the circumstances of course are
completely different kids in schools
most of them have parents most of the
possibility of remote learning
not all i understand there's
communication between schools and
parents and kids
there's an apparatus where the
relationship is completely different
the migrant children at the border you
can't say
we're going to do remote border
facilities where you will be with your
parents and via zoom you will join the
border facility like it doesn't even
compute it doesn't make any sense
the circumstances are completely
different in both cases
the cdc has put out guidelines and
recommendations
the reason the guidelines aren't the
same is because the scenarios are
completely different and what's possible
is completely different
but peter is desperate to have these
gotcha moments and so what is actually a
good topic
gets lost to the hyperbole and
histrionic questions
let's continue with it are is there a
specific school though that is not
following the cdc guidelines of
of implementing the mitigation steps so
they can reopen
the cdc is saying schools you can be at
every school can be at full capacity
the cdc guideline the cdc guidelines
just to be clear because i think this is
very important to be very clear and
specific on
they they gave eight mitigation steps
that schools can take
to safely reopen a number of schools
have actually recently
reopened schools in washington d.c some
have schools in many districts across
the country
but each school district needs to make
the decision about whether they are
able to take those mitigation steps the
president has also been clear
some of these school districts need
additional funding there's 160 billion
dollars
in this package that he's going to sign
into law later this week secretary of
education will be quite focused on
working with school districts to
help them reopen but more school
districts are reopening
more kids are in classrooms every single
day so jenn saki points out
lots of schools aren't open because they
haven't met the guidelines
some schools haven't met the guidelines
because they can't afford to meet the
guidelines without the coveted relief
money
which was finally passed yesterday so
many schools
are soon going to have the money to do
what the cdc recommends
and to get open like that's substantive
that's that's
important this is separate from
what makes sense now you know we we've
talked about
does it make sense or not to open
schools does the immigration policy make
sense or not
i just want to focus on the hypocrisy of
peter ducey
that's created when in reality these are
very different
circumstances he's blinded by his
unquenchable thirst for drama
maybe his desire to impress his dad
who's also a fox news host but
uh he he keeps going and then he changes
his approach a little bit
but since they are not all back from an
administration
position or from your perspective have
the border patrol
unions and the hhs unions been easier to
work with than
the teachers unions i i think that's a
little bit of mixing
different circumstances i would say that
it's children
all in tight quarters uh
i mean like classroom but not quite
funny
not quite so jen saki's opinion
of whether it's easier to work with
border patrol or teachers unions is
really irrelevant
but eventually peter gets to how he
should have started
which is that both the border migrant
centers and the schools are children in
tight quarters that's true
that's the similarity what is different
such that we have different guidelines
that's a fair starting point
it's not the way he went about it here's
just the last few moments of this
i i would say that let's let's take a
responsible approach to the two issues
okay
one is schools reopening there's been
eight mitigation steps that have been
announced by the cdc to implement right
every school district is going to work
to implement those
on a timeline that is uh they can
effectively do many school districts are
reopening right
many are reopening every single week and
day and week
right that is a different circumstance
than what we are seeing at the border so
bottom line
peter has a kernel of relevance wrapped
in a veneer of gotcha and gensake
often handles parts of it well and then
gets a little flustered for other parts
she's she's mostly good at appearing
calm even if we get the sense that she's
frustrated she does
sort of have to be like the patient mom
when the kids are misbehaving
but the important part is that this is
the culture war
sort of framing where the context for
everything is
this is hostility towards law
enforcement
and deference to teachers unions for
example like that's that's one
cultural element of why this is framed
in such hyperbolic terms
or it's a purported left-wing double
standard when the truth is
listen circumstances are different in a
school versus
in a child migrant facility and peter
ducey will likely keep doing this for as
long as fox news keeps him in the
briefing room because my
my instinct is the fox news viewer sees
this
and says look at that he's holding jen
saki to account
and jensaki is doing a terrible job of
answering these questions that's my
instinct of how the right
sees peter ducey's participation in this
and to the extent that they like it
i would expect if places like oan and
newsmax can get back in the press
briefing room
i would expect them to do this but
scaled up like 10 notches
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent role in trump's impeachment
number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
are current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays i really enjoyed
listening to the audio book i think
anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just 499
and you can get it at davidpakman.com
slash takeover or wherever you buy
audio books